Heinrich Himmler – Hitler’s Enforcer
He was the quiet, efficient and oh so ruthless
architect of the Holocaust; Hitler’s most
loyal sycophant.
He ruthlessly dispatched those who stood in
his way as he rose to a position of power
that was second only to the Fuhrer.
In the end he spectacularly betrayed his master
– only to be felled by his own hand.
In this week’s Biographics, we reveal the
cold, calculating life and death of Heinrich
Himmler.
Early Years
Heinrich Luitpold Himmler was born on October
7th, 1900 at Wittelsbacherstrasse 2 in Munich.
He was the second of three sons to Gebhart
and Anna-Marie Himmler.
Gebhart was the deputy headmaster of Landshut
High School and was a pious, pedantic man.
The family was well-off but not rich and they
held a measure of prestige in the local community.
Gebhart had previously been a tutor to the
royal Wittelsbach Princes.
It was this connection that led to the great
honor of having Prince Heinrich of Bavaria
as Heinrich’s godfather.
Heinrich was not a well child.
He was often absent from school with one illness
or another.
Still, he made up for the absences by simply
working harder.
By doing so, he proved himself to be excellent
student.
A middle school teacher remembered him as
‘a very keen pupil whose tireless application,
burning ambition and active participation
in class have achieved excellent results.’
The man who would go on to persecute the Catholic
clergy without mercy, grew up as part of a
devout family of believers.
As a youth he wrote in his diary . . .
I will always love God and remain true to
the Church.
As a teenager, Heinrich served as an altar
boy.
When war broke out, he developed a desire
to serve his country in a military capacity.
Gebhart, a fervent nationalist, approved and
tried to use his royal contact to smooth his
son’s path to becoming an officer.
However, the seventeen-year-old was turned
down by the Imperial Navy due to his short-sightedness.
He next turned to the army, gaining entry
and being sent to officer training school.
But before he had completed his cadetship,
the war was over.
Unlike the Fuhrer he would come to adore,
Himmler saw none of the carnage of the Great
War first hand.
The Emerging Nazi
In April, 1919, Himmler joined one of the
many Freikorps army units that were determined
to crush the Communist movement.
During the next two years he served in various
paramilitary organizations that were on the
march against democracy, the shameful Treaty
of Versailles and the Marxist dictatorship.
Young Himmler had been frustrated that he
had not got to fight in the front lines during
the war and, lacking any direction, he now
sought a cause that he could embrace and a
leader that he could respect.
Himmler’s family had not been inherently
anti-Semitic.
In his early twenties, however, he began reading
the Jew bashing pamphlets that were circulating
around Munich.
He also got ahold of the ‘Protocols of the
Elders of Zion’, a faked document that purported
to contain details of a Jewish world conspiracy.
Himmler came of age at a time when the old
order was in a state of chaos.
The German people were defeated, their economy
decimated and their psyche damaged irreparably.
This caused fear and depression.
In the old order, Himmler, the son of a royal
tutor, would have found a secure place in
society.
But now all bets were off.
He would have to forge his own path.
Gerhard Himmler had instilled in his sons
the Teutonic ideal that the German Aryan was
the master human being.
What Heinrich saw on the streets of Munich
in the early ‘20’s was the opposite of
Aryan supremacy – the people were fast sliding
into decadence and immorality.
But this was no fault of the German people
– his readings convinced Himmler that the
country’s ills could all be laid at the
feet of one group – the Jews.
Himmler would spend the rest of his life championing
the Teutonic ideal.
His constant refrain when faced with a situation
was, ‘What would our forefathers have done
in this situation?’
Disgusted at what had happened to his beloved
German nation, the young Himmler began making
plan to emigrate.
On November 23rd, 1921 he wrote the following
in his diary . . .
Today I cut an article from the newspaper
about emigration to Peru.
Where will I end up: Spain, Turkey, the Baltic
countries, Russia, Peru?
I often think about it.
In two years’ time I will no longer be in
Germany.
A year later he was still in Germany, but
the dream of living abroad was still with
him.
In 1922 he enquired at the Soviet Embassy
about moving to the Ukraine as an estate manager.
Two decades later he would send his death
squads into the Ukraine to decimate the land
and wipe out its Jewish inhabitants, but for
now his greatest ambition was to be a peaceful
agricultural manager.
By the end of 1922, Himmler had completed
a degree in agriculture and settled into a
job as an agricultural assistant in a fertilizer
factory.
Then, in 1923, he joined the Nationalist Socialist
Worker’s Party.
He started off as a member of the paramilitary
unit under Ernst Rohm and played a part in
the unsuccessful Beer Hall Putsch attempt
to seize power.
The police threw several people, including
Hitler himself, in prison.
Himmler was questioned but then released through
lack of evidence.
But his involvement in the attempted revolt
led to him losing his job as an agricultural
analyst.
With no money coming in, he had to move back
in with his parents.
Around this time, Himmler appears to have
fallen into a depressive state.
He had few friends and portrayed an aggressive,
volcanic personality.
The Catholic religion, which had been so dear
to him, was abandoned and a fascination with
the occult began to take shape.
Unlike a lot of other new recruits to the
Nazi party, Himmler was not immediately overawed
by the presence of Adolf Hitler.
His adoration of the Fuhrer developed over
time.
As was his nature, Himmler read everything
he could about and by Hitler.
He came to appreciate him first on an intellectual
level – the worship would come soon enough.
The Loyal Worker
The now unemployed twenty-five-year-old began
putting all of his energies into the cause
of national socialism.
He took on the position of secretary for Gregor
Strasser, a pharmacist from Landshut who was
standing as a candidate for the Reichstag.
In return for a monthly salary of 120 Reichsmarks
he travelled around Lower Bavaria on his motorcycle
and gave inflammatory speeches against Jews
and Communists.
Strasser was a Nazi party member who was attempting
to wrest control of the organization from
the imprisoned Hitler.
Believing that he would succeed, Himmler supported
Strasser in this internal power struggle.
In the early ‘20’s the notoriously shy
Heinrich, found his fraulien – a nurse from
Bromberg named Marga.
Tall blond and blue-eyed, she fit the Teutonic
ideal and matched Himmler’s ideal image
of Germanic womanhood.
The couple were married on July 3rd, 1928
with Marga bringing a sizeable dowry to the
union.
This financial windfall enabled Heinrich to
realize his dream of owning his own piece
of land and they purchased a chicken farm
at Wadltrudering not far from Munich.
During this time, Himmler managed to rise
rapidly in his standing within the party.
By 1926 he was deputy head of Reich propaganda
and then deputy Reichsfuhrer-SS.
By then Hitler had been released from prison,
brushed aside the internal threat from Strasser
and published his tome, Mein Kampf.
Himmler effortlessly switched his allegiance
back to Hitler.
He devoured Mein Kampf, commenting that it
contained an extraordinary number of truths.
Very quickly, Himmler’s loyalty to Hitler
became absolute.
The SS
By the mid-1920’s Hitler came to the realization
that he was in need of a special protection
force.
He needed a squad of men who gave him unquestioned
loyalty and were even prepared to march against
their brothers if needed.
To head such a force no one was as fervently
devoted and therefore so eminently suited
as Heinrich Himmler.
On January 6th, 1929, Hitler appointed Himmler
to the position of Reichsfuhrer-SS.
At that time, the SS was a small division
of the larger SA, which was under the headship
of Ernst Rohm.
The SA was Hitler’s private army.
The fighting quality of its men was questionable,
but Rohm saw its strength coming from force
of numbers.
In contrast, the SS was a far more elite force.
Its members wore black peaked caps emblazoned
with a skull along with black bordered swastika
armbands.
The new position was ideal for Himmler.
From his youth he had admired and been fascinated
by the Praetorian Guard that were the elite
protection force of Roman emperors.
Now he had the opportunity to craft his own
modern day Praetorian Guard.
He immediately began putting his own stamp
on the SS.
He had belt buckles made that were in scripted
with the words . . .
SS man, loyalty is thy honor.
He also came up with a succinct motto for
his men . . .
Be more than you seem.
When Himmler assumed leadership, the SS numbered
around 200 men.
A year later it had grown to just over a thousand.
By June, 1934 it had swollen to 50,000.
In 1931, Himmler created a unit within the
unit.
It was called 1C and was put under the leadership
of new rising star Reinhard Heydrich.
Later to become the secret service, this was
the organ by which Hitler could have undercover
surveillance undertaken within the party.
Night of the Long Knives
By 1934, the SA under Ernst Rohm had become
redundant to Hitler.
Now that he was Chancellor he had no need
for a bunch of street thugs.
In fact, his association with them was bound
to be damaging to his career.
It was time to break this private army up.
Himmler was delighted with the news that the
SA, along with its commander Ernst Rohm, were
about to be dealt with.
For five years he had been a subordinate to
the uncouth and unorganized Rohm, whom he
considered his social inferior.
Himmler threw himself into planning the overthrow
of the SA that history would recall as the
Night of the Long Knives.
Documents were forged to show that the SA
were planning a coup and Himmler personally
took those documents to Hitler.
Immediately death lists were drawn up containing
the names of SA leaders as well any others
who were seen by Himmler and Heydrich as threats
to their growing power.
At the top of the list was Ernst Rohm.
When Rohm was taken into custody, Hitler was
in favor of commuting the death sentence of
his long-term colleague but he was brow beaten
by Himmler and Heydrich into eliminating him.
This was in calling with Himmler’s underlying
nature.
He was a man who was completely devoid of
scruples, lacking any of the normal inhibitions
or pangs of conscience that would cause others
to pause in their actions.
The arrests, torment and murders of the Night
of the Long Knives were carried out by Himmler’s
SS.
Their leader was a major beneficiary of the
operation.
In the wake of the purging of the SA, Himmler
took over headship of the Gestapo from Hermann
Goering.
Around the same time, Himmler ordered the
death of Gerhard Strasser the man he had earlier
supported as Nazi Party leader and who had
been his employer.
Total Power
By 1935, Himmler was in a position of great
power within the Nazi state.
As well as heading the SS and Gestapo, he
was also in command of the entire German police
force.
This enabled him to participate in Cabinet
meetings with all the rights and privileges
of a minister of the Reich.
On October 11th, 1936, Himmler gave a speech
in front of the academy of German Law in which
he made it clear how he was to run the country’s
police and defense forces . . .
Whether or not our actions conflict with a
particular article or sub-section is a matter
of complete indifference to me.
In the fulfilment of my duty, I do precisely
what I can answer for in my work for Fuhrer
and nation, and what equates with healthy
common sense.
Whether or not others whined about a breach
of the law is no concern to me.
Hitler would only accept the very best Teutonic
men into the SS.
The organization was to be a racial elite
class.
Himmler made sure that he saw a photo of every
applicant.
He meticulously scanned them in search of
anything that might give evidence of impurity.
Once he found his perfect specimens, he intended
to do what he could to ensure that there were
more of them.
And so, on October 28th, 1939, he issued his
procreation order to the SS.
It was the highest duty of women and girls
to conceive children by the soldiers of the
SS before they went into battle.
In other words, if a female did not submit
to the sexual demands of an SS man, she was
guilty of treason to the state.
Himmler became obsessed with the idea of procreating
the world with Pure Aryans.
An order went out that every SS man was to
father at least one child.
He considered monogamy to be a sin.
His men were allowed to have several wives
in order to be able to father as many future
heroes as possible.
Mass Murder
Under Himmler, the SS became much more than
a personal bodyguard for the Fuhrer.
Himmler had been charged with restoring the
nation to health.
This task required ridding the country of
racial impurity.
To do this the SS would go through community
after community and cleanse it of Jews, Freemasons
and Jesuits.
But Himmler had soon extended the list of
undesirables to include Slavs, gypsies, homosexuals,
Jehovah’s Witnesses and Communists.
When Hitler invaded Russia in 1941, Himmler
provided ‘action squads’ who would follow
up the regular army as it conquered the land.
Their job was to take out all Jews, Asiatics,
Communist and gypsies.
Himmler ensured that his men keep meticulous
records of their activities.
One of the squad commanders had recorded 90,000
killings in just the last few months of 1941.
These mass scale murders, however, presented
a problem that Himmler had to provide a solution
for.
Having to kill so many people each day was
proving challenging for the psyches of the
soldiers doing the work.
Was there a more efficient way to kill that
did not lead to such demoralization?
Of course, there was no question in Himmler’s
mind that the course of mass murder was morally,
socially and politically correct.
For year he had drilled two simple rules into
the minds of his SS . . .
Firstly, the Fuhrer was always right.
Secondly, the end justifies the means.
He presented the mass extermination as a monumental
secular mission that his men were privileged
to be fulfilling.
After personally watching the execution of
200 Jews near Minsk, he said . . .
It is the curse of the great man to step over
corpses.
In the summer of 1941, Himmler summoned the
commandant of the Auschwitz Concentration
Camp, Rudolf Hoss to a meeting in Berlin.
He informed him that the Fuhrer had order
the final solution to the Jewish question.
The SS, he told Hoss, were to carry that order
out and he had selected Auschwitz as the prime
location to do it.
Hoss and Adolf Eichmann were to organize the
genocide but Himmler was the man in charge.
Under Himmler’s watchful gaze the concentration
camps, with Auschwitz as the shining model,
became incredibly efficient death factories.
Those passing through the gates of the camp
were weeded, with those selected going directly
to the gas chambers.
In less than fifteen minutes they were dead,
victims of the highly poisonous gas Zyklon
B. For those who were considered fit for work,
their death would come from exhaustion or
starvation.
Himmler paid a personal visit to Auschwitz
in 1942.
He watched as victims were selected and watched
through a spyhole in the gas chamber door
as the executions were carried out.
He did not comment on what he saw, a sign
to camp commandant Hoss that he was happy
with what he witnessed.
Himmler went on to inspect the rest of the
camp, during which time Hoss campaigned about
the squalid conditions and the dangers of
disease to his men.
Himmler stopped him in mid-sentence and declared
. . .
I don’t want to hear anymore about your
difficulties.
For an SS officer there are no difficulties;
his duty is always to remove difficulties
himself as soon as they arise.
How you do it is for you to figure out, not
me.
End of the Reich
By mid-1944, the tide of war had turned and
the writing was on the wall for the Nazi regime.
Yet, Himmler’s unwavering loyalty to Adolf
Hitler was intact.
This, being the case, historians have noted
that it seems odd that, with his massive spy
network he did not have advanced warning of
the July 20th, 1944 plot to kill Hitler.
Some have even speculated that he was involved
in some way.
It is true that three days before the attack
he turned down a written Gestapo request for
permission to arrest two of the main plotters.
It is also clear that the ruthlessness with
which the SS persecution machine when into
action after the attack was not matched with
its usually impeccable standard of surveillance
before it.
It is probable that Himmler did not intend
to betray Hitler on July 20th, 1944.
But that betrayal was to come, and it would
manifest itself on the Fuhrer’s birthday,
April 20th, 1945.
On that day, Himmler was guest along with
other high-ranking Nazis at what must surely
have been one of the most macabre birthday
parties in history.
It was held in the underground bunker that
was Hitler’s final hideout, situated in
the heart of ravaged Berlin.
Hitler was unaware that Himmler had a second
engagement later that day; with an emissary
from the World Congress of Jewry.
He proposed that the jews and the National
Socialists bury the hatchet and that concentration
camps inmates would be handed over to the
Red Cross.
Just a few days earlier he had given orders
that no camp survivors were to fall into enemy
hands and no camps were to be surrendered.
His about face was clearly a matter of expediency
in an attempt to minimize the ire of the allies
when they discovered the horrors that had
been taking place under his watch.
Three days later, Himmler held talks with
the Swedish diplomat, Count Folke Bernadotte.
Here he presented a surprising offer, saying
that, in order to save Germans from the full
force of a Russian invasion he was prepared
to surrender the Western front – but not
the Eastern front.
Himmler believed that he could negotiate directly
with President Eisenhower and wondered out
loud whether he should shake the President’s
hand or offer him a Nazi salute.
Of course, Himmler’s clandestine visits
were meant to be top secret.
However, somehow, they got leaked to the media
and on April 28th, London’s BBC broadcast
that Himmler was claiming that Hitler was
dead and that he was his successor.
In the Berlin bunker, Hitler’s adjutants
were monitoring the airwaves and this news
soon found its way to the Fuhrer.
Hitler was dumbstruck.
He could accept betrayal from anyone else,
but never from his loyal Himmler.
He called it the most monstrous betrayal in
world history and he immediately ordered Himmler’s
arrest.
But within days, Hitler was dead, the victim
of his own hand.
An Inauspicious End
On May 1st, Himmler met with Hitler’s heir,
Admiral Karl Donitz at the naval barracks
at Plon.
Donitz was wary.
Even though Himmler had been deposed, there
was no telling how much allegiance the men
of the SS would still give to him.
Himmler was shown his letter of dismissal.
Ignoring it he congratulated Donitz on his
appointment and offered to work with him as
his second-in-command.
Donitz declined.
The meeting was over and Himmler was allowed
to walk away.
He now resolved to go into hiding and bide
his time before coming back to lead his all-powerful
SS on a surge to power.
On May 22nd, with the war over and Germany
under allied occupation, a British patrol
stopped a group of ragged looking men outside
of Hamburg.
One of them, a short, thin man with a black
eye patch told them his name was Heinrich
Hitzinger and then produced forged identity
papers.
He was dressed as an ordinary German soldier.
The seven men were, in fact, Himmler, his
bodyguard and adjutants.
The British guards took the group into custody
and placed them in a prisoner of war camp
just out of Bremen.
It didn’t take long for the proud Himmler
to chafe under the common treatment that he
was receiving as merely a captured soldier.
After a few days he requested an audience
with the camp commander.
Expecting to be treated with newfound dignity,
Himmler announced his true identity.
But rather than being respected for his position
as the Nazi number two man, his captors treated
him with contempt.
He was forced to strip completely and kept
under 24-hour watch to prevent his suicide.
The following day Himmler was brought before
the camp commander for interrogation.
In his mouth he had secreted an ampoule of
poison which had been issued to all top Nazis
and which they always carried with them.
A body search was ordered and when a doctor
tried to examine Himmler’s mouth, he bit
down on the ampoule.
The enraged British tried desperately to clear
the poison from his system.
But it was no good.
Within twelve minutes, Himmler
was dead.